so last week canada finally enacted its
nationwide ban on so-called conversion
therapy our neighbors to the north uh
now join several other countries like
germany and brazil
and uh up to i think 20 u.s states now
in banning the alleged practice though
the canadian law ups the ante
considerably under the statute as the as
the new york times reports it is a crime
to quote
provide or promote services intended to
change or repress a person's sexual
orientation or gender expression and
violators who are found guilty of
engaging in this illicit activity will
be subject to five years in prison and
those who merely don't even engage in it
but promote it are looking at two years
behind bars
now this immediately raises a question
that most corporate media articles on
the subject have uh not really bothered
to answer a pretty obvious question
which is
what is it what are we talking about
what's what specifically is
conversion therapy we've all heard the
the phrase before
but what is it now left-wing propaganda
about the practice which often uses
words like barbaric and violent and
brutal to describe it brings to mind
images of homosexuals you know committed
against their will to insane asylums in
straight jackets maybe strapped to
gurneys and given electric shocks until
they change their mind about their
sexual orientation
but that sort of thing isn't happening
in the modern western world
so what then do these conversion therapy
prohibitions actually prohibit
well for that answer we should probably
turn to the legislation itself i think
it's probably the best place to go
bill c4
which begins by telling us that quote
conversion therapy causes harm to
society because among other things it is
based on and propagates myths and
stereotypes about sexual orientation
gender identity and gender expression
including the myth that heterosexuality
cisgender gender identity and gender
expression that conform to the sex
assigned to person at birth are to be
preferred over other sexual orientations
gender identities and gender expressions
now
in one fell swoop here
um
sexual morality as it is understood by
billions of people across the world and
throughout history and has been taught
by every major world religion for
thousands of years
has been legally consigned to the status
of myth
and the belief that it's better for a
person to accept their biological
identity than to than to try and reject
it in favor of an identity that they can
never truly obtain
a belief shared by nearly every human
being who has ever walked the earth
joins biblical sex morality under the
fairy tale umbrella because that's a
myth too
but we still don't know what exactly
conversion therapy is right
now fortunately there's a section of the
bill which purports to offer a
definition in fact it says definition of
conversion therapy
okay that's good now here's what it says
conversion therapy means a practice
treatment or service designed to
a
change a person's sexual orientation to
heterosexual
change a person's gender identity to
cisgender
c change a person's gender expression so
that it conforms to the sex assigned to
the person at birth
d repress or reduce non-heterosexual
attraction or sexual behavior
e repress a person's non-cisgender
gender identity or f
repress or reduce a person's gender
expression that does not conform to the
sex assigned to the person at birth
and then it continues and says for
greater certainty this definition does
not include a practice treatment or
service that relates to the exploration
or development of an of an integrated
personal identity such as a practice
treatment or service that relates to a
person's gender transition and that is
not based on an assumption that a
particular sexual orientation gender
identity or gender expression is to be
preferred over another
now the wording here is still quite
vague um by by design i mean this is
intentional
but it's clear that conversion therapy
certainly need not involve straight
jackets or electric shocks
so we're way beyond that
any practice treatment or service
you think about the word practice
what is a practice it's just a thing
that you do so just anything at all
which seeks to in any way
quote change or repress a person's quote
non-cisgender identity or
non-heterosexual attraction is
conversion therapy
and could land you in prison for half a
decade
now under this definition
um there is no conversion taking place
when a young boy is say chemically
castrated in order to make him look more
like a girl
or when a young girl is given a double
mastectomy in order to make her look
more like a boy you know that's not
conversion rather it is conversion
if they are convinced not to be
butchered in this way
if you convince them not to do this
if you convince a girl not to go have
her breasts chopped off
then you are guilty of conversion
therapy
for convincing her to keep the body she
was born with
by encouraging a boy
to accept the fact that he is a boy or
encouraging a girl except the fact that
she's a girl you are engaging in
conversion therapy under this law
it is conversion therapy to explain to a
male that he is male
and to help him embrace his natural
identity
if you simply said to a boy well you're
a biological male that means you're a
boy that's conversion therapy
according to this
now does that mean
that any counselor therapist teacher
pastor or even parent who refuses to
encourage a child's gender delusion is
guilty of violating this law and could
end up behind bars for five years
yeah that's explicitly what it means
does it mean that any priest or minister
who stands at the pulpit on sunday and
preaches about sexual morality
not a lot of them doing that in canada
or in the united states but if they do
it
or even read a passage from the bible
like you know romans uh 126-27
one of the
many biblical passages which condemns
the homosexual act um does that mean
that that anyone who does that is now a
conversion therapist and liable to a
lengthy prison sentence yeah again
that's very clearly what it means
once again the prohibition includes any
practice treatment or service
wording that encompasses literally
anything that anyone in any position
might do or say to contradict the
radical left's hair brained theories
about sex and gender
now there is ambiguity here um tyrants
love legal ambiguity because it gives
them free reign to do essentially
whatever they want you know but there's
there's no subtlety
so notice how the bill specifically
forbids the repression of
non-cisgender and non-heterosexual
identities but does not forbid
repression the other way so it is
expressly not a crime
to impose transgenderism on a child or
homosexuality on a child
it's only a crime in the reverse
and the law is written that way that's
the way the law is written
you cannot as it says
change a person's gender identity to
cisgender
but there's nothing forbidding you from
changing it to trans
it would have been easier clearer and
less wordy to prohibit all attempts
to change or repress a person's
sexuality or gender but the bill very
conspicuously does not do that
i mean why doesn't it just say uh it's a
it's a crime to change a person's gender
identity
period
no they they specified which direction
you're not allowed to change it in
that's because the demented leftist
despots and child predators who are
behind these anti-conversion therapy
laws
they don't actually have a problem with
sexual coercion or manipulation
they have a problem with heterosexuality
and biological science
and that's what this is really about
and they also of course have a problem
with religion
and this is an effort to criminalize
religion i mean this this is it would
not be an exaggeration to say that this
is a criminalization
of
every of all the abrahamic religions
because um
one of the most crucial aspects of their
moral teachings are are
verboten now
legally so in fact if the term
conversion therapy means anything at all
the only sort of conversion therapy that
happens in the western world is the sort
that converts people away from
heterosexuality and biological sex not
into it
i mean only an idiot or a partisan could
look at surveys showing that 40 of
generation z identifies lgbt and
conclude that this is some sort of
natural evolution 40 percent
we're talking 300 400 500 increase
in a couple of years
now we can be sure that if this was if
there was a pronounced drop in lgbt
identities if the lgbt communities uh
community if the ranks of the lgbt
community were to shrink
over the course of a few years
rather than have this astronomic rise
the left would conclude without
hesitation that there must be a
conspiracy
of repression and eradication at work
here
and that is exactly what's happening but
going the other way
there has been a many-fold increase in
non-straight non-biological identities a
jump unlike anything the world has ever
seen period
and there's nothing accidental about it
the lgbt lobby is as i've been saying
for years running the most successful
recruitment drive in american history
and it's pretty easy for it to be
successful because they have the media
the school system corporate america and
the government on their side
you know it's easy to win converts when
you have all of the most powerful
institutions in the world working with
you and especially when your target
audience are children who don't know any
better
good example this a video went viral
over the weekend showing one conversion
therapy victim uh kind of go off script
unexpectedly
the child's mother put him in front of a
camera for a tick tock uh video for a
tick tock live you know answering
questions and the idea was he was
supposed to deliver lgbt talking points
the ones he'd been assigned because
that's all that this child is to this
mother he's just a vessel
um
for for lgbt propaganda but you know
kids say the darndest thing sometimes so
here's how that went
white people that aren't like serial
killers like ted button does your mom
say you have to be lgbt i'm not no i
think she's what i want to be but some
fun
go ahead let's fight keep talking stay
with yourself
my mom doesn't matter if i'm up if i am
gay or a lesbian or any of that she
doesn't care all she cares about is that
i'm a part of it
and if i'm not a part of it she'll try
to convince me to i'm go join it because
i
what are you saying right now
facts that i would convince you to join
what the algebra a plus
now if the child in that video had said
that uh his mother was trying to
convince him to be straight
you know the police would have barreled
through her door
and carted her away in handcuffs by now
instead he reveals that he's being
psychologically conditioned to be some
version of gay
and his abuser will pay no price for it
there'll be no penalty no punishment
this is the approved form of conversion
therapy in america
and in
the western world
millions of children fall victim to it
it's the only kind of conversion therapy
that's allowed
and the only kind that exists
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content